come on through the coast we get
together have a few laughs
it's likely in experiences scenario with
your family or friends sitting down in
front of the TV to watch a Christmas
film and someone mentions die hard the
debate begins diehard is not a Christmas
movie why not
because it's just not a 2018 poll found
62 percent of American adults didn't
think die hard Ward's a Christmas film
but I wanted the 38% that believes that
it's not Christmas until Hans Gruber
falls from gakuto B Plata I'm going to
look at the following criteria to settle
the argument for good time frame music
emotional drive anti-christmas elements
viewing traditions so you can all see
why die hard is the Christmas immunity
firstly as a film have to be set around
Christmas to be considered a festive
film Christmas films normally set in the
run-up to Christmas or actually on
Christmas Day sticklers could argue that
there are some films set in or around
Christmas that don't feel particularly
Christmasy like Iron Man three or three
days of the Condor but their stories
aren't dominated by Christmas there's
nothing that explicitly links the plot
or current to motivation to Christmas
time diehard is set during an office
party on Christmas Eve and Christmas is
the entire reason that you're McClane is
even in LA so it meets the time relevant
criteria and gets a check from us
does containing a festive soundtrack
make the film a christmas film
festivities are often filled with
uplifting or soaring scores that reflect
the magic and joy of holidays I spoke to
a composer about what kinds of music we
see in Christmas films in Christmas
films we often get pieces played in the
piano and this is because as composers
we know that many people have pianos at
their home or piano is an instrument
really commonly found in public spaces
and this allows us to feel a connection
with the music that we're hearing we
have songs also piano scores and strings
brass can create this really punchy
sound the die-hard soundtrack contains
accessible well known family favorites a
whistled a cappella rendition of jingle
bells piano chains the brassy let it
snow let it snow let it snow and overall
just a load of explicitly Christmasy
shoes so that's another take for
die-hard which brings us to does a film
have to contain a recognizable moral
pattern Scrooged Miracle on 34th Street
the plot of a classic Christmas film
seems to base around someone learning a
lesson doing the right thing we also see
this in contested Christmas films like
frozen or Harry Potter which feature
characters following a moral compass
like the ghosts in Christmas Carol
Sargent power and die hard
acts as a spiritual guide for the
central character you know when you're a
rookie they can teach you everything
about being a cop except how to live
with a mistake another constant is that
greed is overcome the pursuit of
material wealth is replaced with the
characters learning the true meaning of
Christmas family love an appreciation of
the gift of life we see this throughout
die hard the John McClane reconnecting
with his estranged wife and the downfall
of attempted robber hands Gruber so
that's another tick for die hard but die
hard is a violent action movie surely
that can't be a Christmas film normally
at this point festive haters would pop
up and say what about plain old
Christmas horror
black Christmas Jack Frost they're not
really Christmassy because like diehard
they're not about family hugging and
rainbows but think about it some of the
best Christmas films also have
disturbing plot lines however lo2 is
essentially about a small child being
chased around the city that he doesn't
know by two seasoned criminals but it
still has a spirit guide pigeon lady
overcoming of greed and appreciation of
family also nasty things happen to
well-intentioned characters Richard
Attenborough sections in Miracle on 34th
Street and don't even get us started on
the tongue lamppost scene in a Christmas
story Christmas films suggest that
violence itself allows us to appreciate
family just like having an argument
around the dinner table movie violence
is cathartic and purifying James Stewart
crashes into a tree starts a fight in a
bar and tries to kill himself in what's
considered the greatest Christmas film
of all time It's a Wonderful Life in die
hard
McClane is Moody and dismissive he
sneers it a couple embracing at the
airport and gets annoyed about his limo
driver being almost too young doesn't
sound very Christmasy right wrong he's
not exactly dressed up as a Grinch but
McClane fits into the archetype of a bad
center or Scrooge almost all classic
Christmas movies have a character like
this and the violence in the movie
befits our the Christmas films - so
that's another cake for die hard
there's watching a film at Christmas
make it a Christmas film it's likely
that you think of die hard as a
christmas film because it's always on TV
anyway during Yuletide I asked a
programmer at the British Film Institute
what he thought is there is the most
Christmas movie is a film that we
associate with the holiday period it's
played every Christmas so I think if you
have that warm feeling when you watch
that film and that associated with the
holiday spirit why shouldn't it be a
Christmas movie and die hard okay it's s
instead of Christmas is it specifically
Christmas movie well it's got a message
around trying to get back to
Christmas with your family that's that
that's this kind of you know raison
d'être throughout that film so in a
sense yes so if you're in the habit of
watching a film in late December
it's a Christmas film that's another
tick the die-hard according to someone
who knows what a Christmas film should
be I mean it also opens the door for
pretty much Eddie film as long as it's
watched around Christmas but that helps
my argument so I'll stick with it this
might be the reason why polls have
skewed age group opinions about what
constitutes a Christmas movie there are
more traditional over 65s only 19% of a
squiz say diehard was a Christmas movie
compared to 42% of 18 to 24 year olds so
your parents might not agree with you so
if you needed any more convincing john's
wife is called holly like Holly and the
ivy and in the film we see Christmas
trees terrible Christmas jumpers and an
awkward office party so it's a clean
sweep for die-hard it meets all of our
criteria of course we did make up all
this criteria ourselves and judge it
ourselves but we'd like to know whether
you agree in the comments below
you
[Music]